are we alone in the universe I've always
been persuaded by the pure statistical
argument that given the scale of it
there's bound to be and you mentioned
yourself you talked about there's loads
of planets and the Goldilocks on uh all
around the universe surely there's
intelligent life somewhere out there
right statistically speaking right so so
that I like to make the the following
analogy so I believe that there's no
intelligent life in the universe yeah
especially if I mean especially on this
planet yeah that's right this this
planet's uh the worst except for all the
others yeah
um so uh I believe that we become very
uh enamored of this notion again there
is some primordial Beauty to the notion
of escaping and thinking about things
that transcend our limitations of time
or space or existence and one of those
is the existence of other life forms
that may exist in in the universe first
of all we can say there's zero evidence
for such life forms even a slime mold on
Enceladus you know in our own solar
system there's no evidence for it and
that's important because uh there is a
concept purported by by the man who
coined the term Big Bang actually you
guys are the perfect people asses I've
never gotten a straight answer is Big
Bang a dirty word is it a dirty phrase
no no no because supposedly Hoyle Fred
Hoyle sir Fred Hoyle is one of the
greatest astronomers in history he
coined the term Big Bang as a pejorative
meaning orgasm ah so that's never said
in this country we had a better sex last
night
uh no I didn't know that no I don't
think it is nobody would do it so he was
he was a proponent of the steady state
model uh but but in any case he uh the
he also came up with the notion of
what's called panspermia can I say that
on the show yeah whatever you want it's
a free speech it's a free speech on
great so the notion of what's called
panspermia it means that uh that there
will be exchange of material between
planets and between other star systems
in our galaxy and that will potentially
uh be a an almost like a Noah's Ark for
life to transport it doesn't solve the
origin of life problems but it could
potentially solve the abundance of Life
problem in our solar system or how how
did it come here he claimed could have
come from another another planet uh not
too far away by Cosmic standards so it
gets here now I actually have some of
this and as we said there's meteorites
and so forth there are found in
Antarctica it's well known phenomenon I
actually have a tiny piece of Mars it
doesn't have any amino acids or DNA or a
little uh green met on it but its games
comes from Mars and we can prove it
comes from Mars uh just trust me we have
it from many other bodies in our solar
system so why is that important that
means that things can come here well
guess what that means that things can go
from the earth out there right so you
have to answer the question what is the
probability and what does it say about
life in the universe that we haven't
found life say on Mars now Mars a big
place and yeah if we went somewhere on
Earth but almost everywhere on Earth has
life almost everywhere even Antarctica
where I've been Antarctica is
one-seventh of the total number of
continents on this planet it's about the
size of Australia uh so it's pretty it's
pretty big there's almost no life there
though there's almost no there is life
there's microbial life there are these
giant birds called skuas uh that will
like take a toddler away if the toddlers
were allowed on the content notes or not
um and then there's sea lions a couple
Penguins on the coast that's about it
there's no polar bears or anything like
that
um and then there's humans so you're
talking about you know this vast
continent the size of Australia hundreds
of times you know tens of times bigger
than the UK
no life almost no life but if you make
the argument that life should be
abundant or based on statistical
probability as Fermi did Enrico Fermi
one of the greatest physicists he
created What's called the Fermi Paradox
there's so many planets there's so many
goal they didn't know about the
Goldilocks zone back then but they said
if uh if the average lifetime of a
technological civilization is even a
million years then just in the age of
our galaxy which is which is maybe eight
billion years or more uh that means we
should have been visited by thousands in
that even going at a slow chemical
rocket speed so he asked the famous
question where are they
so we have to ask where are they and and
come up with solutions to that Fermi
Paradox and there are many purported
solutions but one of which is there are
no aliens right I mean the most simple
thing based on evidence is that there
are no certainly technological
civilizations that we're aware of there
could be beyond what we're uh where now
the best calculations do the following
they don't say and as I don't say I
don't say there's no life I say the
probability is very small uh and
certainly even smaller for technological
life it has to be even smaller right if
there's a dolphin swimming on a pool and
Enceladus we're never going to know
about it because it doesn't have an
iPhone to let us know that we live there
unless we stumble upon it right so it
has to be technological how do we get to
that technology comes back to what we
said before we started with primitive
things maybe our hydrocarbons necessary
is global warming a trademark a Hallmark
of civilization some say it is in other
words we should look not for uh
Transmissions of you know I Love Lucy
but we should look for global warming on
another planet so far we haven't seen it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist but that
would mean terraforming and modifying
the that particular client then did they
have a biosphere
did they have chlorophyll do they have a
great oxidation event did they have a
Jupiter that sucks up deadly asteroids
from impacting the the Earth or whatever
the analog Earth is in the Goldilocks
zone that's not in the Goldilocks zone
do they have a moon that's at the exact
right distance to create tides that can
cause chemical intubation almost between
life Land and Sea do they have plate
tectonics that we talked about are those
plate tectonics lubricated by these
microorganisms so there's many different
hurdles and the way I like to say it is
so you can phrase it like this imagine
that there were eight things that had to
happen for us to have this conversation
under these Lights and Camera right that
had to be a big bang you know there had
to be uh the formation of matter from no
matter so people think that a matter is
conserved it's not energy is conserved
but matters not then there had to be
primitive elements that could support
life then life had to come about be
conscious then that life that was
conscious how to create technology and
so forth so you just go through and you
say it like this and then there had to
be things that prevented it asteroids
are going to be dinosaurs that got that
were there but got killed off and
fossils and so you didn't say there's
eight of them and each one has a
probability of one in a thousand that's
it just say one of the Thousand that
there's a big bang whatever that means
one of the Thousand that there's a
Jupiter one thousand and we know the
probabilities are much much much much
lower let's just say for the sake of the
argument one divided by a thousand eight
of those you take one over a thousand
you raise it to the eighth power you get
one in ten to the 24th that same number
is the inverse of the number of planets
we think there are in the observable
universe's history so over 13.8 billion
years we think there have been 10 to the
24th which is a trillion trillion
planets that could be life inhabiting
but the probability I just said is one
in 10 to the 24th so that so the problem
comes about the human mind is incapable
of multiplying a zero by an infinity and
that's why the statistical argument I
think is a very crude but often
overestimate of the probability of
possibility of technology so
the emergence of life on Earth is so
ridiculously unlikely that's right that
for that to be replicated anywhere in
the universe even with the number of
planets that exist is still
extraordinarily unlikely because it was
so unlikely that it was formed here yeah
and there's so many contingent things
that have to occur it's just the right
order which brings us inexorably to the
final question of the three that you
always get asked yeah which is about
where life comes from yeah so
foreign